منزل المرشد الاعلى للجمهوريه الاسلاميه
خامن اي يحترق بعد ان ادرب فيه المتظاهرون
النار كرد على السلطات الايرانيه وظهرت
موجه من الاستحسان لهذا العمل مثل هذا
الفيديو الذي صورته سيده
احسنتم احرقوا بيت خامنئي واهنئكم
تشهدوا ايران في الايام الاخيره اعنف
مظاهرات منذ ثلاثه اشهر شعارات قويه
[تصفيق]
شمال ايران تصعد العنف اكثر
الحريه للنساء سنواصل للنهايه
اليوم
الاخيره ما اسفر عن مقتل اربعه اشخاص
بينهم الطفل
عندما كان يستقل سياره والده وقد شارك
الالاف في مراسم الجنازه والقوا باللوم
على قوه الامن الايرانيه
واحده من اكبر الممثلات الايرانيات تفاعلت
مع الوضع بالدموع
اوقف هذه المجزره اذا كان خلعي للحجاب
يساعد في دعم الاحتجاجات اذن هذا اقل شيء
افعله
في طهران اطلق رجال الامن الرصاصه بمحطه
المترو الانفاق كان يختبئ فيها متظاهرون
وداخل المترو ردد المحتجون وكتبوا كلمه
العار
بدورهم اغلق التجار محلاتهم التجاريه